oui d'accord tonton mari actuel deux
hommes ont compté dans ta vie jean-noël
fenwick moi mais je vois je suis prêt à
tous les patients n'auront pas partie ça
s'arrête
ouais des coluche oui énormément
énormément alors raconte moi comment tu
l'as ensorcelé dans un studio d'europe 1
un jour est bien autre dans le bon et
masi et qui marchait pas du tout 1
et à l'époque on se disait quand même
c'est entre nous on pensait que notre
spectacle à juste titre d'ailleurs été
très rigolo et devait marché puisqu'elle
avait cartonné au festival d'avignon
donc vos cd mais il faut il faut pas
qu'on laisse ces spectacles comme ça
s'est cassé la gueule et on s'est dit
mais qui peut donner un coup de main
alors on était sept comédiens et on
avait chacun ulysse de 700 journalistes
toi comme toi à toi maintenant et on
qu'on devait absolument contactés pour
leur demander s'ils manquent pas de
parler des missions évidemment on avait
filé les nanas ou mais qui filmait
canada et moi sur ma mise en tête de
ligne avec coluche toit s'est dit
comment je vais faire et tout et puis
j'ai un copain qui est beau c'est au
guichet à europe 1 il va vivre à coups
de tu viens et je te ferai rentrer tu te
plantes dans le studio depuis le quai
juste en fin de l'émission commenceront
direct à 15 heures donc tu débarques à
15h15
c'est bon bah évidemment j'ai aucune
idée de ce que pouvait être le direct
vient donc je me suis planté
puis à 15h15 et ouvert le fameux studio
qui fonctionne et puis je suis arrivé
évidemment l'émission s'est arrêtée
maudit menuck situe félin et tout comme
ils disent testud fin et tout je dis
bonjour je m'appelle charte de turckheim
a déjà morts de rire évidemment
charlotte comme vous ma chère de turcs
rmc tomberez non enfin dix mois bref il
dit mais tu c'est là qu'on est en train
de parler qu'ils nous entendent en vrai
et tout moscou avait plus tôt révisé le
voir libre on va puisque taylor assieds
toi qui étais à dire et tout un
spectacle avec des copains ou magiques
et tout et tout voir et on voit la salle
a fait marrer puis m'a dit et puis quand
les artistes ont besoin d'être homo
d'iveco les aristos fond du spectacle
brun est synonyme acteurs de radio il a
donné un coup de pouce
oui plus que certains disent à quoi
s'était c'était extrêmement platini
construit un mois j'étais c'est vrai que
tu es sûr c'était pathétique entrevue
ben oui parce que si tu veux j'étais
extrêmement amoureuse et ce garçon tu
allais souvent au gaz ont quand même
oui écrit souvent se passait rien rue
gazan web entre lui et moi entre lui et
toi vous voyons voir sa remise passé
rien ne rend jamais couché avant tu
crois mais personne ne me croit c'est
marrant c'est marrant comme chaque fois
que tu le dit entre pop non une asbl
demandes de droit je crois qu'il me
croit pas je vous aiderai comment est-ce
que je ne sais pas ce côté du bric est
ce que tu lui as fait le coup du peintre
direct à coluche c'est quoi ta un franc
10e tu connais pas le temps entre 10 et
15 9 en amour ou non